[Music]
thanks for the nice introduction
as an overview for today i'll be
presenting uh some details about the
microfluidics products that will feed
into the second presentation that would
be presented by justin
so as an overview for microfluidics
since i recognize it may not be a
familiar term for many of you i'll be
providing a basic overview of how
standard biotools genomics products and
microfluidics
contribute to
the testing being performed in true
graph
also getting into how microfluidics
compares with traditional
microwell plates
and the benefits provided to the end
user on the opportunities for automation
of our microfluidics as well as workflow
and next generation sequencing library
prep and then finally concluding with
supported applications
giving an overview of the various
products within the standard bio tools
portfolio we'll start with our
instrument systems and you can see on
this slide we're showing you the the
juno on the left biomark hd and c1
system those are respectively used for
ngs library prep
the biomark hd is used for our it's our
kind of our powerhouse for
genomic p or
pcr based applications and then c1 is
used for single cell applications on the
far right i'm showing a picture of
biomark x which is the latest generation
of our biomark series um it was released
earlier this year and i'll be providing
a little bit more on that later in this
slide deck
moving
moving into the next
segment we've got our integrated fluidic
circuits which are also referred to as
ifcs or perhaps you might hear them
referred to as chips these enable
processing of tens to thousands of
instrument controlled nanoscale
reactions per run and i'll be providing
a bit more detail on this in an upcoming
slide as well
we have our consumables with the goal of
providing a complete validated
product bundle or kit for use by our
customers
and then finally for those who are doing
custom applications we do have a custom
service whereby you can contract with
them it's it's a no charge service and
they can work with you to design assays
based on the needs of your applications
i mentioned the ifc which may not be a
term many of you are familiar with and
it is a foundational technology that
enables standard biotools to automate
various genomic applications at
nanoliter scale so some of the features
of our ifcs are they perform multiple
pcr-based applications including
targeted ngs library preparation
they scale they can scale sample
throughput without changing technologies
and by that i mean we have different
formats of ifc so depending on what
sample volumes you may have today as
needs change you could always pivot to
one of our other ifc formats to either
increase or decrease your volumes
we can achieve lower cost and higher
operating efficiency through volume
miniaturization and workflow automation
so basically once the ifc has been
loaded with the samples and the assays
it's a load and go situation
they're designed for the ability to add
remove replace and replicate assays on
demand so since we're not operating in a
multiplex format
each assay sample is its own reaction
chamber and they're controlled
independently so you don't have the
challenges of a multiplex reaction it's
more high content without the compromise
of multiplex since none of the assays
are prefixed on the on the ifc and then
finally it is automation compatible we
are designed to work with upfront lab
automation systems so for high
throughput labs they can automate the
delivery to the ifcs
some of the key features and benefits of
the ifc design are showcased in this
slide you can see the dimensions in the
center those are basically the same
dimensions as a microwell plate so it's
designed to have the same physical
footprint as a micro well plate they are
gas permeable so the elastomer
composition prevents microscopic gas
bubbles that could impact results from
getting trapped in the channels
they're automation friendly as i
mentioned they can be worked they can be
used with various automation lab systems
because they are the same size as micro
well plates so anything that a micro
well anything that can process a micro
oil plate can process our ifc's
they're optically clear so that it makes
it it makes it possible to view what's
happening within the reaction chambers
we've got our rnd team routinely sets up
microscopes and you can easily see
what's happening within the individual
reaction chambers if you needed to do so
they're also flexible with an open
architecture that allows users to
determine the order and frequency in
which samples and assays are loaded onto
the device as i mentioned earlier you
can easily change add or remove assays
as needed over time
they they utilize microscop or
microfluidic engineering expertise so we
do have engineers in house that have a
specific expertise in microfluidics
and that that lends itself to
development of different ifc formats
that can control thousands of valve
chambers to deliver the performance
that's needed for any particular ifc
they are economical since you're working
at the national later scale reactions
are set up using less reagent and sample
than traditional microwells which
reduces both waste and cost
and then finally they are precise since
these are controlled through our
instrumentation
these are we provide scripts that ensure
metered flow of reagents and samples to
specific reaction chambers that offer a
more controlled environment than
microtiter plates
i'll go through this slide fairly
quickly just another view of the center
part i wanted to focus on the reaction
chambers in the middle since you could
see the sample inlets and the the acid
inlets and previous slides i've kind of
expanded the scale so you can see the
reaction chamber showing where an
individual reaction chamber gets input
from one sample inlet as well as one
assay inlet and there are thousands of
these within the matrix in the center of
the ifc and this gives us
the a lot of it allows for combinatorial
processing
within each independent reaction chamber
and it allows up to 100 fold lower real
volumes because we're working at the
nanoliter scale
a common comparison with micro with
ifc's is the micro well plate format and
so on the left you're seeing a
traditional microwave format where
you've got your assay mix and your
sample master mix and you deliver each
of those to the appropriate well of the
plate
and as a result each sample is
interrogated only by the targets within
the same well so it is it is possible to
multiplex and you can it's not uncommon
to do four or five maybe even six
different targets within within a given
well but as you start getting into
higher multiplexes that drives you to
have multiple wells
allocated to a given sample so for each
well that requires additional sample
volume additional reagent material to
complete the reaction and it can add to
the cost
by comparison the ifc-based pcr format
you've got the same assay mixes and the
same sample mixes but everything is
independent you don't have any
multiplexing going on as i mentioned
earlier each sample is interrogated by
every assay within the independent
reaction chambers so you get the benefit
of a lot of data without the challenges
of a multiplex
so some of the advantages of our format
they do support up to 192 targets per
sample
they facilitate workflow automation as i
mentioned earlier
minimize the use of expensive enzymes
and master mixes conserve usage of
precious samples
they're easy to optimize multiple
targets since everything's independently
allocated throughout the plate it's easy
to add remove change and replicate
assays and they are designed to maximize
throughput based on which format of ifc
you employ for a given
a given application
so kind of focusing on the the
simplicity of adding changing assay
sometimes it's easier to see that in
reality versus just hearing it in spoken
word so on this slide it's designed to
kind of show you the assay inlets on the
right
and in this case there are 48 open
inlets of which i've i've utilized 45 of
them you can see the three and the
bottom are empty we routinely do this
and recommend this to users to leave a
few open inlets in the end so that over
time if you ever needed to add something
you can add additional assays or in the
case of this purple in the middle of the
of the of the field we've changed out an
assay we took out the
original blue assay and replaced it with
a pink assay um and by nature of showing
this this change didn't affect any of
the other assays in the matrix um
everything's independent so by changing
out one assay or adding in one assay
you're only making a change to the inlet
in which that change occurs
the other key benefit i mentioned is a
cost one with our ifc's relative to
microtiter plates and we've had a number
of customers especially in the high
throughput settings where they've shown
how much data you can generate with
micro microfluidics relative to a
microplate so if you focus on the table
on the bottom of the screen
and look at the two parameters pcr
reaction volume and the number of
reactions our ifcs operate at the
nanoliter scale versus the microtiter or
microliter scale for microtiter plates
and we have up to
9216 independent reactions whereas a 96
well plate is limited to 96 and the the
result is you end up having
a case where you can generate as much
data in a single ifc as you would in 96
96 well plates or the same amount as 24
384 well plates so over time you can see
it can take a while to run 96 96 well
plates so you're also saving not only on
reagents but you're saving on time
we've got a variety of formats available
for ifcs starting with our most simple
on the far left that are basically
designed for reaction partitioning and
if you progress from left to right
they've become more sophisticated over
time putting more of the workflow onto
the ifc itself so some of our more
recent designs they are designed to both
capture the target that you're
interested in there are multi-step
reactions that occur on the ifc itself
such as pre-amplification or rt-pcr and
then in the case of library prep they're
designed so that once the amplicons are
barcoded on the ifc
you can harvest all your samples into a
single tube because everything's been
barcoded and you can now tell the
samples apart as you progress downstream
to
next generation sequencing
for our systems we have the juno system
shown at the top which is considered a
preparatory system
it's designed for both library
preparation for next generation
sequencing but it also processes all of
our ifc formats so it's deemed a
universal controller
and it is capable of an overnight
operation you can program it to set up a
run overnight so that if you wanted to
do one run during a normal workday and
then you've concluded that run and you
want the instrument is now free you
could start a run let it run overnight
while you're away and then program it to
be available when you're ready to come
back the next day so that's one of the
features that i think a lot of our
customers enjoy using
from juno you can go into two directions
you can either go into next generation
sequencing so our systems and designs
are compatible with all of the aluminum
platforms we all we can do in addition
to targeted dna sequencing we can do
rna-seq from total rna
using polyadenylated targets
and then on the right if you're using if
you're kind of going down the pcr route
you would go to biomark hd for gene
expression or real-time pcr quantitative
pcr i'm genotyping which is more of a
qualitative result sample id copy number
variation testing as well as digital pcr
um i mentioned the biomark hd early on
and i showed you a picture of biomark x
and a small little thumb print i wanted
to take a moment just to introduce our
latest in the series of biomark
platforms called biomark x
it sets a new standard for automated
real-time pcr to maximize
your lab proficiency or productivity
as well as with minimal effort and
training since it's designed with the
touch screen so that it's easy to use
and walk up to and start running from
day one
it supports the same applications with a
smaller footprint allowing you to
generate a maximum data output by
smaller footprint this system is the
size it's 1 6 the size of the
predecessor and as you can see it's a
single system it does not require a
separate controller it does not require
a separate computer it's everything is
is built into this one platform which is
about the size of a desktop of an old
fashioned desktop computer
it's also integrated all the systems are
now in one and it has a co it has an
intuitive user interface to make it easy
for the operator to
engage the system at any given time
and it's intuitive as i mentioned with
the user interface i'm designed for
modern uh technologies and it has a
modern components to make use of what's
been developed over the last five to ten
years in the industry
the biomark x is part of our overall
streamline workflow where we now start
by preparing master mixes and samples
and detection assets up front loading
those onto the ifc itself
take that loaded ifc deliver it or
transfer it onto the biomark x for
cycling and imaging um the the ifc when
the final results are available and then
those final results can be sent to any
office computer for analysis um using
our different software packages the
overall workflows as you can see on the
slide is about two to six hours
depending on the workflow and depending
on which ifc format you're using but in
all cases
for genotyping and gene expression the
the workflow involves about 30 minutes
of hands-on time so it's most of the
operation is automated
are designing our applications to cover
various areas um with our the various
tools that we provide so starting from
the upper right or i'm sorry upper left
we do offer targeted dna seek library
assays as well as gene expression or
real time it's also referred to as
real-time applications we have offered
genotyping applications a molecular
sample id
we have a diagnostic product for sars
kobe 2 that is under the
fda's eua ibd the emergency use
authorization
we have products that used for copy
number variation digital pcr single cell
analysis rna sequencing and more are in
development to make um the the biomark
series a very comprehensive
and capable system in the lab
my final slide is basically just to show
you the various applications that either
we have developed as standard biotools
or have been developed by our customers
using our products starting with cancer
investigation looking at somatic
variants in cancer or gene expression
signatures to guide treatment we've got
customers who've done this for k rats in
colon cancer
and they're also other customers are
looking at solid tumor driver analysis
as well as immuno oncology markers
we offer screening more on the germline
variants for inherited disease an
example of this is cystic fibrosis
testing looking at the cftr variants
associated with cystic fibrosis
we offer translational and clinical
research applications for genotyping
correlations with disease phenotype this
would as an example would be
brachavarians and ovarian cancer
and then scrolling all the way down the
line you can see we've got products for
pharmacogenomics pathogen detection
microbiome testing surveillance and food
supply um crop and ag bio is a key
market for us we've got a variety of
customers using our products in novel
ways there and then finally in
transplantation which brings me to the
close of this session is an is a nice
segue over to justin who will present
the next portion of today's webinar
well thank you bill for the introduction
and thank you for handing it over
so um as you know my name is justin
weems i'm the director of research and
development
and also the director of the laboratory
operations for transplant genomics
division of your offense
so
we'd like to start today and talk a
little bit about what the presentation
outline will look like so we are your
finch transplant genomics but the
question is uh who are we and and how
are we relevant to whatever space that
we're talking about today in biomarkers
we'll also talk a little bit about why
what is rejection why is it important
and how are we utilizing
gene expression profile testing to
address the question of rejection
then we'll touch
significantly on the conversion of the
from the biomark hd and the pcr and then
finally the effect on on what our
biomarker testing is called with true
graph and omnigraph and we will go from
there so
um again uh you know we are a division
of europeans a uh large conglomerate
that's a international corporation that
has a number of business units across
the united states um in particularly we
are part of a group of eurofen's
transplant diagnostics
and we make up three different groups we
have some pre-transplant testing which
is donor screening hla testing and
microbiology testing that goes from a
company that we call that used to be vrl
but now is dpt or donor product testing
secondly there's infectious disease
that is done by a sister corporation as
well
urophan's viracore and then we are
within rejection testing and treatment
optimization i'm in post-transplant
testing and so we are transplant
genomics sometimes called pgi for short
so our mission at transplant genomics is
a personalized diagnostic company is
really to be committed to organ
transplant outcomes and improving those
outcomes worldwide through innovative
tests and our tests
are designed to detect early signs of
graft injury to differentiate among
actionable causes and really to allow
for the optimization of therapy and
immunosuppression
so what is rejection and why is
rejection important to us
so within the the idea right now that
there's a spectrum of immune activation
and rejection following kidney
transplantation it's important to
understand that every time an organ is
transplanted within a patient that that
organ is trending towards rejection and
the reason is because the host or or the
recipient does not recognize that that
is a life-saving organ what it
recognizes that it's a foreign invader
in their body and how it reacts and how
the immune system in that situation
reacts is really indicative of of what's
going on under the surface so here we
have time of transplant
and and over a course of time where you
can see a couple of different things
there's uh towards the top you can see
protocol and surveillance biopsies in
the green area there's also an area that
says biopsy indication and then those
are biopsies that are done for cause so
protocol or surveillance biopsies are
basically routine biopsies that are done
without any clinical suspicion of
rejection and so they're just looked at
simply to see what is going on at
specific intervals of time
indication or for cause biopsies are for
a change in something like creatinine or
egfr and a number of different ways
where there's clinical suspicion of
what's going on so there's two types of
rejection that we concern ourselves with
within this this context for kidney
transplantation is one is is subclinical
acute rejection or sub ar and the other
one is clinical acute rejection or car
and what the difference is between the
two of them is subclinical rejection or
sub ar
is not going to have any changes in
serum creatinine any changes in egfr and
this is considered to be a sort of a
silent rejection that we have going on
so you can kind of see from the graph
that there's inflammation that's going
to flow from the sub ar that is
ultimately can if untreated leave to car
where the clinical rejection is taking
place and the four cause biopsies are
indicating that but these subclinical
rejections have traditionally only been
caught through surveillance biopsy
because the patients are stable and
there's no outward signs of what's going
on
importantly as these rejection events go
on
chronic injury and fibrosis or if the
builds up over time and this leads in
part to how we're experiencing rejection
and how rejection is is thought of
so
how do we expand our view about what we
do so again you have you have a graph
that is that is really agnostic to time
you have course progression and then you
have a couple of different things the
first thing we think about is this
transcriptomic alteration or
transcriptomic window this is a gene
profile indicating that the genes have
changed and the genes eventually will
manifest into a morphological alteration
where the protocol biopsy window might
be able to detect subclinical rejection
or ifta
of course then after that there can be
clinical alteration where this clinical
window is indicated by biopsy and that
could be protoneuria it could be gfr
loss rejection ifta
and elevation of serum creatinine so
when we think about transcriptomic
morphological and clinical alterations
it's important to understand what true
graph and what tgi is trying to do and
where we're trying to approach this
problem
so really this starts with the idea of
transcriptomics and that you have dna
that gets transcribed into rna and that
rna gets translated into protein
ultimately what tends to happen is that
we have dna changes that end up in rna
changes and then it takes a little while
for the protein to catch up the protein
then will cause the structural and
functional damage to the kidney that is
going to be detected by after biopsy or
during a biopsy
so it's important to understand this at
tgi the the gene expression test that
we're looking at is actually capturing
at the rna level and we're capturing at
the rna level to see if we can figure
out and understand the mechanism of
rejection prior to translation and prior
to the physical damage that's already
occurring
so on the graph of of injury when we're
looking at a kidney
we are exploiting two different
mechanisms here one is the rna of course
and then the other is going to be
our um
our other one is going to be our cell
free dna product that is capturing
injury so here on the left hand side you
can see transplant is where we start
the very first thing is that when a
patient comes in with low serum
creatinine we expect these patients to
be immune quiescent or have a calm
immune system
true graph is measuring the gene
expression changes of the alloy immune
response that's detecting the
subclinical rejection that's happening
further down the line is the injury
threshold for donor derived cell free
dna and cell free dna is really an
indicator of clinical acute rejection or
clinical injury so one thing is that the
gene expression is actually looking at
the patient or the recipient's immune
response cell free dna is a measurement
of the actual graft and what happens as
the graft is undergoing damage apoptosis
and necrosis the graft dumps out the
donor derived cell free dna
into the bloodstream and by taking a
measurement of that ratio of how much
donor derived cell free dna
is in the patient's bloodstream we get
an idea of how much graft lofts that
patient has had so it's really a late
marker of injury and after the injury
has already occurred so if we can catch
the gene expression changes beforehand
that would really help us identify early
rejection cases
so i've used the term gene expression
profile
a little bit now and so the question is
the what and the how of what gene
expression is so i think the first thing
that i'll tell you a little bit about is
how biomarker discovery is important
then we'll discuss a little bit about
what the previous technology was where
this test was designed and then again
hit the conversion to the biomark hd and
pcr and how that has enhanced what we've
done
so one of the things is that there's an
ideal pipeline for developing clinically
usable and useful biomarkers in renal
transplantation
so there's what's considered to be a
pre-clinical phase a clinical phase and
then of course a market and so what we
do within those those perspective phases
is look at a lot of different things on
the left hand side you see preclinical
phase where these are pre exploratory
studies so a lot of the omics
transcriptomics genomics proteomics
looking at a lot of different things and
some of this can be basic science that's
derived from candidate biomarkers
beyond that then we move into this
clinical phase
clinical phases are characterizes in
part by looking at retrospective studies
where you can go back and use highly
selected cohorts or unselected cohorts
and look at longitudinal design to
determine whether or not a biomarker was
actually capturing something not in real
time but in the in the retrospective
analysis of that then we do have
prospective studies and prospective
analysis that kind of bridge the gap
between the clinical phase and the
market where these are randomized
clinical trials or controlled and
designed standard of care designed to
understand whether or not
the test is performing in the metrics
that the lab said it could perform it
the data that i'll show you today is is
largely in the clinical phase and this
is in the retrospective studies and
analysis that we've done in part with a
clinical trial uh called see todd 08 in
conjunction with northwestern university
so really understanding what this test
has been prior is is really big to us
and understanding how we moved forward
so the first thing is that the true
graph kidney test was was currently on
microarray technology prior to the
launch of the biomark um
the biomark switch and so really one of
the things that was hallmark about the
microarray test is that this is a
cumbersome test that really took about
five to six days from rna extraction all
the way to analysis at the very end
characterized by these three overnight
incubations that took a really really
long time to do that now when we're
talking about microarray microarray is
actually like a three-dimensional
stacked puzzle and there are a number of
gene targets that are on a plate and you
flow the rna over the plate and you're
looking for hybridization or stickiness
and you can see these red dots these are
these are luminescent dots where the
where that will light up if you get a
match now part of this is is that each
gene has multiple probes on there
but it's also sort of an indirect
measurement of gene expression because
you're looking for a three-dimensional
match in real time now the risks of this
of course include orientation base pair
changes incomplete hybridization
fragmented fragmentation and also what's
what's called small non-coding rna that
you could have a a probe that maybe has
100 base pairs and you might be able to
match five to ten base pairs at any
random time and it would prevent the
actual match from being able to stick
so what this does is this character this
was hallmarked by a lack of sensitivity
now microarray is a very good technology
for discovery it is very good at telling
you on off up down but it doesn't tell
you the nuance of how much it's on or
how much it's off
so in part what we decided to do is is
to look at this in a very different way
so again we do a peripheral blood draw
we do an rna extraction and
traditionally we went to the left side
of this schematic here where we did rna
gene identification via microarray we
had 120 gene proprietary classifier then
puts out a phenotype that characterizes
the patients as either having transplant
excellent meaning that they have immune
quiescent as our negative test or it's
positive for gene activation and
indicating that the genes are
sort of moving in the direction of
activation
now what we changed is moving over to
the way that we identify the genes via
the pcr system so by identifying the
genes about around the pcr system we've
enhanced the sensitivity and i'll share
with you the metrics as we kind of
navigate this um shortly so i showed you
the process of the p of the microarray
being a five-day process
now i share with you this this true
graph kidney technologically improvement
that we've seen with standard biotools
and the biomark hd in particular so we
again we prepare the samples we do rna
extraction in a very similar way but now
we're looking at the genes in response
to the the 120 genes in the pcr-based
system so then we transfer to an ifc and
get processed on the juno which again is
the liquid automated handler that you
heard about earlier and then of course
the amplify detect on the biomark hd
which is our pcr machine and then we
analyze the data that comes out of that
so again one of the important things is
to think about how the dynamic range of
sensitivity changed across the two
different technologies
and so we're thinking about the
practicality of the qpcr versus the
microarray methodology and a publication
of a few years ago about looking at at
mrna expression using microfluidics
dynamic ranges uh in the biomark but
also thinking about what's what's
happening with the gene array um it kind
of gives us an indicator of how this
changes so on the vertical axis is the
log fold change on microarray and i've
drawn two red lines to indicate to you
basically the high and the low of full
change that we're being able to see with
the with our uh microarray type
technology and you can see it really
goes from about three to about minus one
fold change which indicates there's
about a four-fold change that we're able
to detect within our our microarray data
now when we look at what happens when we
move over to the biomark suddenly we see
a huge increase in that dynamic range
and it really opens up to about 13 fold
difference that we're able to see
in the sensitivity by going to a pcr
based system and in particular
using microfluidics of standard biotools
and what we're doing with the biomark hd
so this ultimately is our is our
practicality for how what we're doing
that and so as we did this conversion we
wanted to think about what the data
looked like and how did this enhance
this
so again just to reiterate what the gene
expression profile is is it's a it's a
test that looks at rna and it's designed
to confirm quiescence
and we're looking at the gene expression
profile of two reference populations
with stable renal function
the biopsy is confirmed as either normal
histology or that sub-ar subclinical
rejection
and so our test reports out a binary
result a negative test
that is an immune quiescent and that is
a normal histology and it is clear of
subclinical rejection um traditionally
reported out as tx but we're navigating
away to a negative positive um for to
for ease of use the positive test of
course is the not tx and that is not
transplant accidents in the case where
further evaluation may be necessary and
the profile looks more similar to that
of subclinical rejection
the intended use that we have within the
assay here is as an alternative to
surveillance biopsy and kidney
transplant patients with stable renal
function who are 90 days post-transplant
also in aiding and thinking about how
immune
immunosuppression medications can be
optimized and also thinking about how
the kidney is doing at any given time
and as clinically indicated
so what does our technological evolution
look like well looking again to the ctoc
clinical trial study and the validation
samples where we have a multiple of of
over 800 biopsy paired samples on the
left-hand side we looked at microarray
as a test utilizing some bioinformatics
as random forests uh
the test that we had
gave a negative predictive value of 87 a
positive predictive value of 45
using now the standard biotools
pcr-based system at one time called
fluidized using the exact same random
forest approach we enhance both the
positive predictive value from 45 to 65
and we enhance the negative predictive
value from 87 to 92.
now importantly what this has allowed us
to do is not only have a more sensitive
test or a more sensitive assay to
actually understand it but it actually
allowed us by using microfluidics to
reduce the amount of blood necessary and
rna necessary to process
these samples for our patients and so
what we really have is two tests as i
told you about a gene expression test
where it's pre-injury it's the earliest
immune activation test that you're going
to be able to see
changes indicating that rejection could
be a possibility and that something
might be brewing on the surface
track our viral core track is our donor
derived cell free dna product that i
mentioned earlier where it's sort of a
late marker of renal dysfunction and
together we've combined these two tests
into something that we at tgi
have launched as omnigraph omnigraph
enabling earlier smarter clinical
answers by combining complementary
biomarkers sensitive to different types
of rejection for a better diagnostic
confidence to allow physicians to more
uh to provide more coverage on the types
of rejections that we have
so as i say this the next thing in is
sort of to to finally talk about what
the effect is on the true graph genotrix
expression test and then how that
changed our omnigraph
so in data that was published
in cjson um with uh northwestern um in a
number of of our collaborators the
microarray data of looking at at the two
different biomarker tests that we have
the cell free dna and and the uh gene
expression tests are on the left hand
side
and then the data that's been recently
published on the journal of
transplantation and technology research
um is the data that has been done with
uh standard biotools
formerly fluidized
indicating how these metrics have
changed so this this venn diagram is is
is a busy slide to try to navigate so
what i'll do is just draw your eyes to a
couple of different things the first
thing is is on the peach side that the
square those are biopsy proven rejection
events the bluish square on the other
side are the biopsy proven normal events
the green circle is the donor derived
cell free dna
positives and then the orange circle is
the true graph gene expression positive
tests that were indicated from there so
what you're seeing is is you'll see on
the left hand side there are
there's 27 21 and 23 respectively
indicating that's how many biopsy proven
rejection events were captured by the
biomarkers and listed as our true
positives so you can see the true graph
one alone at 23 samples
and so when we think about what happened
when we changed over to the pcr based
system is that that 23 number went up to
36 indicating to us that we captured at
least 13 more rejections and again if
the if the goal here is to capture
rejection this is what we're enhancing
by going to a more sensitive methodology
within the pcr based system
second to that is the 45 these are the
ones that the true graph score called a
rejection event but the biopsy disagreed
and we saw no rejection in the biopsy
sometimes those are called false
positives
and and so what we see there is that we
reduce that number to about half we
reduce the number of what is true
considered false positives one thing i
would say though is when we think about
the gold standard of biopsy is that
biopsy is actually a moving target so
it's not actually a hard and solid gold
standard and importantly what true graph
is capturing sometimes might happen
before the biopsy is showing damage so
it's really important to think about how
gene expression is related in that omics
pathway that i mentioned earlier and how
these things are navigating together
finally the thing that i'll mention is
actually the false negatives so both
tests came back negative but 32 of those
tests were shown to have a biopsy proven
rejection event again we reduced that
number by half and that was really
really important but i think overall
what you can see from this venn diagram
is that when we think about biomarkers
sometimes people use metrics like npv
and ppv sensitivity specificity and then
think that they're comparing apples to
apples i think the most interesting
thing about this data as we published
this was that the overlap between the
two tests the cell free dna and the gene
expression is not a hundred percent so
the question is what is cell free dna
doing and what is the gene expression
doing because they don't overlap
so when we looked at this more closely
we we decided to drill into the idea of
the type of rejections that are
happening so again the green is going to
be a gene expression profile that's our
true graph score our blue circles are
going to be the cell free dna positives
and really it's split into three groups
it's antibody mediated rejection acr in
the left hand corner it's anim it's amr
so i'm sorry t-cell mediated rejection
in the upper left-hand corner the
antibody media rejection in the
right-hand corner and a mixture of both
acr and amr in that bottom uh quadrant
right there
and so again you know a busy slide but
let's highlight a couple of key points
here is the first point here is that
we're actually capturing a number of
different um rejections by looking at
the two types of tests you can see that
from the the true graph aspect you went
from 16 tests to 29 tests and you can
actually see that the four tests that
overlap that are highlighted here from
the cell free dna we're all captured by
our true graph test as well and this is
by changing over to a new technology
second to that you see that the 10
reduced from 19
and those were
19 tests originally that true graph
missed it has now been reduced to only
10 tests that true graph didn't capture
and it's increased the number of that
overlap from 12 to 21
and finally you can see that it's
capturing a number of the mixed
rejections within there and so really
when we think about all of these
rejections there were 103 rejections
that were in this cohort and there's
about 19 of them that both tests missed
but there's only 17 that that the gene
expression missed when we switched over
to a different technology again when we
went over to the pcr based technology
and so ultimately what you see is we
reduce that number and we're capturing
more rejections by using the true graph
pcr we did not change anything in the
cell free dna product and so it's really
important to understand that the
enhancements here that we're getting out
of this are simply because we have gone
from a microarray technology to this pcr
micro microfluidics technology
so the the last thing uh before i i hit
some some of the um other things to talk
about would be that that we what we've
done at tgi at transplant genomics is
try to increase the biomarker diagnostic
performance to a new standard and we've
utilized technology to be able to get us
there so when we first launched true
graph microarray you can see in the
orange bar on the left hand side that it
was a 48 91 percent positive and
negative predictive value respectively
the track cell free dna has very similar
performance metrics now what we
did in conjunction with northwestern
university is to publish uh data for the
very first time to show how the two
biomarkers can be complementary to each
other and so even though they have
similar npv's they're ruling out
different types of rejections
and so you can see with the c jason
paper that we increased our positive
predicted values from the 40s all the
way to the 80s by just looking at a
double positive predictive or a double
negative in their predictive values
and then in the next month or two we
looked at the true graph pcr getting it
off of the microarray technology onto
the biomark hd and enhance the positive
predictive value just a little bit more
now this is what we have overall our
commercial available product now which
is the omni graph where you get the true
graph pcr plus track in this in one two
that in one report is now we have when
both tests indicate um positive we have
a positive predictive value of 89
percent
almost 90 percent making it the highest
positive predictive testing on the
market
when both tests are negative indicating
immune quiescence and no injury we have
a 94 negative predictive value so when
we think about what this is done and
what this is doing for our patients our
clinicians and getting us out there is
that by combining the test we have
created something that has a high
positive and a high negative predictive
value but importantly this
this change was facilitated by getting
away from the lack of sensitivity that
we found in microarray and onto a more
sensitive more technologically advanced
solution with the biomark hd
so now we offer this as a single six mil
routine blood draw so previously you had
to have three different tubes to be able
to draw multiple tests and now we've
simplified this to one simple blood draw
that can be done in a normal of
different ways and also
no special packaging that comes with it
no cold packs no shipping it frozen or
anything like that with high level of
stability that comes with that secondary
to that of course is one easy to
interpret longitudinal report that is
showing you what is happening both for
true graph and track over the course of
time and hopefully providing more
granular detail for the patients and
clinicians to better gauge the health of
the kidney overall
so again combining these tests i think
the biggest thing that i would say is
that by looking at gene expression or
looking at cell free dna alone true
graph or track you are not giving full
coverage of potential rejections on both
sides here so by combining this test and
offering this we provide the value of
offering two tests um and one two one
report that has been really really
important in navigating this uh moving
forward so with that i appreciate your
time and i'm happy to answer any
questions that you may have
you